hi I am Missy Franklin I am an Olympic
swimmer and my favorite movie is Bend It
Like Beckham I would say Bend It Like
Beckham influences means an Olympic
athlete just because it was so inspiring
watching Jess as as an athlete as a
woman and kind of having to fight so
much to really truly do what she loves
it's just something so inspiring about
that that really motivated me as an
Olympian my body tells me know quite a
bit I put it through a very vigorous
routine every single day work out about
four to five hours a day and swim 12 to
13 thousand meters a day and there's
many times in my body says no I don't
want to do this this is tiring and I'm
exhausted and and I just want to rest
and it's those moments where you need to
tell your body yes that it can do this
and that you are capable of achieving
your goals honestly I think my favorite
scene from Bend It Like Beckham is the
first time she puts on shorts and she
has the burn on her leg and she's really
nervous about going out onto the field
and showing her burn and see Jess like
get up from that and go onto the field
and sort of show herself to people in a
way she's never let people see her
before and overcoming this thing that
used to shame her that now it doesn't
matter because she's playing football
and that's all that she really cares
about that was a really inspiring moment
for me watching Bend It Like Beckham and
and seeing Jess's situation it really
gave me an appreciation for mine I had
never really known anything different
than having a supportive family that was
a hundred percent behind me whatever my
decision was and so to watch Jess in her
situation and watch her parents really
struggle with the fact that she wanted
to be a football player and especially
you know running around in short shorts
and like having her mom be upset about
that and being against kind of what they
believed in I had never experienced
anything like that and it's something
that I never want to take for granted I
live my dream every single day being
able to go to the Olympics has always
been a dream for me but also just doing
what I love every day is a dream come
true for me I love that I get up and go
to practice and see my teammates and I
get to work so hard and that's why I'm
so grateful to have that opportunity and
I know not everyone gets those same
opportunities and that
I want to make the most of mine I am
Missy Franklin and I love movies